ينضم إلي الآن من تل أبيب جدعون
ليفي، كاتب عمود في صحيفة حاريت
والمستشار السابق لرئيس الوزراء الإسرائيلي السابق
شيمون بيريز، نقدر
انضمامك إلينا، شكرًا لاستضافتي، لذلك
اتفقت إسرائيل وحماس على تمديد
فترة التوقف في القتال لمدة
يومين آخرين حتى  السماح بالإفراج عن
المزيد من الرهائن مقابل إطلاق سراح
السجناء الفلسطينيين وتقديم
المساعدات الإنسانية إلى غزة، فما هو التأثير الذي يمكن أن
يحدثه تمديد الحقيقة المؤقتة على
المستقبل السياسي لرئيس الوزراء
نتنياهو، كما ترى روزماري يومين هما
يومين فقط والسؤال هو ما
يلي  هذين اليومين حول
استمرار الحرب إذا كانت
ستستمر، وحول سؤالك حول
استمرار مسيرة
نتنياهو المهنية، نتنياهو في رأيي هو
رجل يمشي ميتًا
سياسيًا، فهو لن ينجو من هذا
الفشل الذريع الذي هو مسؤول عنه  لكن
لن يمسه أحد حتى
تنتهي هذه الحرب، وقد لا
أتهمه بأي شيء ولكن قد
يكون ذلك أيضًا بمثابة اعتبار له
لإطالة أمد الحرب. آمل حقًا ألا يكون هذا هو
الحال ولكن قد يكون كذلك
لأنه طالما أن الحرب مستمرة،
فلن يمس أحد نتنياهو نانو، فقد
خسر، فقد فقد، كما ترى في
ظهوراته العامة، ليس الأمر
أنه عندما تسمع ذلك في
حزبه، يتحدث الناس بشكل مختلف عما كان عليه
قبل السبعات، لذا فالقادم
سوف تظهر الفترة إلى أين ستصل الأمور ولكن بحلول
نهاية اليوم ليس لدي شك في أنه
سيتعين عليه التنحي بطريقة أو بأخرى،
لذا فأنت تقول إنه من
المفيد سياسيًا لنتنياهو أن
يواصل هذه الحرب، فهدفه بالطبع هو
لتدمير حماس ومن الواضح أن هذا
يعوقه هذا التوقف في القتال لذا
فهو يوضح تمامًا أنه بمجرد انتهاء
الهدنة المؤقتة ستستأنف الحرب في غزة
قال ذلك بنفسه لقد
أخبر أه الرئيس جو بايدن أن القول
إنها ستستأنف بكامل قوتها  لكن
هل لغة كهذه تساعد رئيس
الوزراء أو تؤذيه سياسيا نظرا لأن
عائلات هؤلاء الرهائن قد
نجحت في ممارسة
ضغوط كبيرة على نتنياهو
وحكومته لبذل المزيد من الجهد من أجل الرهائن
والتركيز بشكل أقل على تدمير
حماس نتان، نحن نرد على سؤالك
إنك من خلال التهديد بتجديد الحرب فإنك
تفعل ذلك أيضًا من أجل إطلاق سراح
الرهائن لأن هذا هو أكبر
نفوذ تمتلكه إسرائيل الآن لذا
يجب أن يكون هناك فرق أو
قد تكون هناك فجوة بين الكلام
والتهديد والأفعال. أنا شخصياً
أتمنى أن تستمر الحرب.  لن يتم تجديدها
لأنها خلقت بالفعل ما يكفي من
الكوارث لكلا الشعبين ولكن
ليس من حقي أن أقرر الآن ليس هناك
طريقة أخرى سوى الاستمرار في
الحرب لأن هذا هو نفوذه ولكني
آمل أن تكون هناك بعض الديناميكيات الجديدة وبعض
الضغوط الأمريكية  سيمنعه من
العودة إلى ميادين القتل تلك إلى
ميادين الدمار تلك وأتمنى أن
يتحقق أحد الهدفين دون مواصلة الحرب
وهو إطلاق سراح جميع الرهائن